- So, that's it. We got to the gala.
I think that's the title,
"Getting to the Gala."
Let's go, Jets.
- [Female] From when we
first started he's gotten
so much more flexible.
Like in every part.
Like his back, his hips, everything.
His hamstrings.
- And last night was like?
- Zero. Zero, because I ate
a good amount at breakfast.
8:07 a.m. got caught up with the kids.
So, rushing 8 a.m. breakfast.
Hate being late.
Worst feeling, but little
investor breakfast right now.
I'm networking with an Angel,
Series A investor.
Are you just getting in?
Oh, yeah. A little daily vlog.
You want to get a little?
- Hey. What's up, everybody?
I just had an amazing
meeting with Gary Vee.
He just blows me away every
single time I meet with him.
He's so inspirational.
I remember when he started VaynerMedia
five years ago,
and it's just like grown
into this massive company.
- [Gary] Eric, this is a very rare moment.
This is one of the few times
you will ever have a
meeting where the Jets won
and the Patriots lost.
- You know, I thought this would come up,
but I didn't think it would
come up this quickly.
- [Gary] Yeah, pretty
much came up immediately.
- Yeah, I really don't want to talk about.
- [Eric] I'm Eric.
I rejoined VaynerMedia about
four or five months ago now.
I was here in the early days 2011.
And what I'm working on with Gary
is I'm working on opening a London office.
So, we're gonna open an office
in London for VaynerMedia.
I came on board to work with
him, work at the office team,
and trying to figure that out.
- I'm Bob Agani, how
are you? You, too, brother.
- Doing daily vlogging, he's always there.
Where do you live, man?
- I live in Arizona.
- Very nice. Nice running into you.
- You, too, brother.
- I don't want you
missing the fan moments.
All right. Good morning.
What is it DRock?
11:04, got in four
substantial meetings already.
Obviously my life's breaking down into
running Vayner and doing
VC investing behavior.
So, we went two and two on those meetings.
So, it's good allocation
of two and a half hours.
Now we're headed to,
the part that I think this
vlog is gonna allow me to
show a little bit more of,
which is I think people
are always asking me
how do I balance my family life.
So, right now we're going
to Xander's Hanukkah party
at his preschool.
It's been fun. I really didn't,
for a long time,
break my day up with family.
But my kids are growing up,
and they're having these events.
I'm absolutely hacking an arbitrage
and making sure that I'm spending time
on the important things.
So, I'm excited that, when I'm in town,
if they've got stuff going on at school
or any of their activities,
I'm desperately trying to
carve out the time to be there.
So, we'll run over to that now.
How are you?
Mickey Cloud, he runs
the Chattanooga office.
Yo, Mickey, how are you?
Good, brother.
How was your weekend?
That was huge.
God, I wanted that one.
We always want to be consultants.
We always want to get paid for our advice.
We're not in the masonry business,
but at the end of the day it's their call.
We just never want them
to feel like we're not,
we're always gonna be passionate
about the best advice.
Hold on one second.
You know what? I can
jump out here, my friend.
Yeah, because it's just
right here in the corner.
I'll walk one block. Thank you.
What's up, sissy. Phew is right.
Looked bad there for a while.
(Gary laughs)
Poor mom.
Mom and dad are four and O.
Mom was probably secretly losing to lose,
secretly rooting to lose,
because she didn't to go to (inaudible).
I mean, she's like, I'm like,
"Mom we're going to Dallas."
She's like, "Ugh."
I had to catch up with my sis.
How you doing, Kev?
Cool, man.
Brian ready?
Hey, Bri. How did the
rest of the meeting go?
12:14, D-Rock.
Not a moment to spare.
TIme to call Brando.
Is the second email the 699?
(Inaudible)
A hundred percent sweeter.
I'm so pumped you guys were there.
We got a lot we got to figure out.
I love you.
I love you more.
I love you, ma. Bye.
- No, I've been out of the country.
So, I recently came back on Sunday.
Oh, yeah.
- I haven't been playing,
I'm getting back though.
Sup, tall dudes.
- Oh, what's up?
- Literally the ebb and flow of the news
was going with the game.
As it was a problem,
the Giants were scoring.
You guys lost the most.
- I don't want to talk about it.
- Good news and bad news.
- Give me the bad news first.
- So, there are not first
class seats from Miami to LA.
- That's bad news.
First class, if you can. Okay.
- Dinner tomorrow I just
texted you about it.
- Yeah, I just text you back. I'm
trying seven different people.
I've got two days
recording them audiobook.
No, I'll get it out in two days.
- One's 9:00 to 6:00, one's 9:00 to 4:30,
but we could make it 9:00 to 6:30.
- Can they give me 1:00 to like,
I'll be in the studio until
fucking 4:00 in the morning.
- I'll ask. If they can't move,
I can tell them that you can get there.
I'll take a coffee.
You cut your hair?
- No, just not wearing a hat.
But I did cut my hair.
- Do we need to sign a consent form?
- No, I am your consent form.
- Hello.
- Hello, how are you doing?
Can we do this in your office?
- Yeah.
- Let's do this in your office.
I want to get your guys's
read on (inaudible).
Kind of what we're trying to do.
I just want to do it one more time.
I want to have a good pulse on it.
170, right?
- [Group] Yep.
- Let's do it.
Ready to go?
Hey, everybody. This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
And make sure you watch
tomorrow's DailyVee.
I'm excited about this, DRock.
I think we're up to something.
1:20 videos for client, cool. All right.
- [DRock] What time is it?
- It's 1:20.
Guys, thank you so much for the
thing that matters the most,
which is your attention.
Great.
What's up, VaynerMedia.
It is your CO, Gary Vaynerchuk.
Zach, I want you to say it
to DailyVee at 3:00 o'clock
the new site goes live.
- New site will go live
at 3:00 o'clock promptly.
- What is that?
No, way.
Did it just come in?
Is this how thick it's gonna be?
I mean, I know it's gonna be hard covered.
This is why DailyVee's so awesome.
The fact you get to...
This is it, huh?
Feeling good, Zach?
- [Zach] Feeling good.
It's a lot of emotions right now.
- [Gary] It's cool, right? It's cool.
- It's cool. Too many things
going on right now but I like it.
- Did the feedback from
the email list help a lot?
A lot of good stuff?
Anything major major?
- [Zach] Nothing major. A lot
of the stuff was stuff that
Caroline and I kind of knew about already.
But some of them were pretty helpful
and offered suggestions.
- Awesome.
- Amazon they sell at $2.74.
Brandon said would GV
want to match Amazon's price.
- 100%.
- So, $2.74?
- Yep. Yep.
Hey.
- How are you?
- Good.
Live stream with Leo. Legend.
I'm gonna Periscope for a second.
Why don't you tell
everybody what I'm doing,
and then just step out and
tell them what the link is.
You know what I mean?
We gotta get Stunwin here.
Say hello.
- Hey, Leo. What's up, man?
Oh, dude. I'm fangirling so hard.
I've been watching the TWiT network since
before you guys were doing
TWiT live for a million years.
Cheers. All right. Break a leg.
- You have a shitload of wax in your ears.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
(laughs)
Thank you. I'm super pumped.
That's that, you know.
It would be, wow.
Anyway. Thank you so much.
Have a great holiday, everybody.
Take care.
Thanks, Leo.
Hey!
- How you doing?
- Really good. How are you?
How's it going?
- Good.
(inaudible)
- [Male] You have to leave by 5:30
and you already have a 15 minute meeting.
- Good news is the answer
is I will see her for
three minutes.
Okay, I'll be right back in one second.
I just told him it's gonna be a 20.
News is I'm willing to there.
I just don't know what
the hell's going on there.
- Hi, I'm Jessica Will.
I'm an account manager.
The experience is good.
It's always a little nerve
wrecking going to meet Gary.
I haven't met him before,
but he's super personable
and very into getting to know who you are,
how you feel about the company,
and how he can help.
It was super helpful.
- Hey, I'm Pam Merritt.
I'm the director of recruiting
here at VaynerMedia.
If I were to say any one thing
about that meeting is that
what you see is what you get with Gary.
Seems like a great guy
to you, he really is.
He's a great guy to us.
- Cool. Gabe, you're good.
- Let's start the conversations
of what's on your mind,
what's on my mind.
I'm gonna take a piss.
- There's gonna be dinner
tonight. Keep it light.
- I may not eat again today.
- [Mike] It's gonna be like a
nice sit down dinner though.
- Yeah. I'll do the right thing.
Thank you.
I'll be there in one second.
I haven't seen you all day.
- I know. I was gonna interrupt twice.
- Are you in a good mood?
- I'm in the best mood.
- Me, too.
- Steve's a Giants fan,
so we're celebrating.
- Steve's won four Super Bowls.
We haven't been to any.
He'll be okay.
At this point is you can tell
we've gotten a shitload
of stuff in on the day.
Very typical day.
As a matter of fact, what
I wanted to kind of jump in
while I had two minutes
here to talk about was
how pissed I am at so many of
you that have been following
me for a long time talking about,
"Whoa, after watching 001.
Wait a minute. That's a lot.
"Oh, that's what it takes.
"Oh, that's hustle.
"Oh, it's great to see it for real.
"Oh, I didn't realize it's so much."
I was really pissed, because I was like,
"Yeah. What do you think?
As a matter of fact,
what was so ironic about
the day we did the first episode was
unfortunately a good friend of
mine and a business associate
his mother passed away.
So, as you saw on episode 01,
I had to go do a Shiva Call,
which wiped out my entire
evening of 7 p.m. to
midnight meetings, five
different meetings.
And what I thought was
so ironic was reading,
and, first of all, thank you
so much for the feedback,
because the comments are my oxygen,
reading all those comments,
everybody talking about,
"Oh, that's what he does.
"Oh, crap. There is real hustle"
It was funny, because that
contradicts what I walked into.
Because when I got home, 10:30 11:00,
Lizzy literally looked at
me, as I walked in, and said,
"Why are you home so early?
What are you doing here?"
And I was already reading the comments
on the next day,
and I was showing Lizzy.
And she was like, (hisses).
It was such a funny moment with my wife.
I'm excited about it.
I'm enjoying this process.
And I want you to know
how much it means to me
that you're watching.
But most of all, I'm
excited because I guess,
I didn't realize this when we did it,
I guess this is gonna help put
a cherry on top of the sundae
of the work is the work.
There's no talking about it.
There's no going on The
#AskGaryVee Show and
pontificating about it,
but then not actually living it.
I mean, some people write things like,
"Oh, I heard entrepreneurs
don't work that much."
I was absolutely
intrigued by the feedback,
and I'm excited for you guys
to continue on this journey,
because get ready to be very exhausted.
We have two minutes, right?
- Two minutes to you is a lifetime.
- But not for everybody here.
We have two minutes then all hands off.
Okay.
- Are you listening to me?
- Yes.
A hundred percent now.
I don't understand. Let's go.
Brandon, I don't give a shit.
Let's go.
Dylan, let's go.
Yo, all hands. Now.
Yeah, let's go. Let's go.
What's the matter with
you guys? What the fuck?
I knew 15 was gonna fucking shit on this.
Let's go, guys. Let's go!
It's fucking 5:01.
I don't understand this.
What the fuck!
What about 5 p.m. do we
not understand around here?
Yeah, all hands. Let's go.
All hands, not some hands. Let's go.
All hands, not some hands.
Let's go, James. I see you.
That's a lot of employees.
Good afternoon.
As I continue to kind of pay attention
to the pulse of the company,
I think we're handling
this day of the year
better than we ever have before.
Which speaks to maturity
and the confidence
and things of that nature.
So, I think it would be appropriate,
mainly because I like loud sounds,
right now for everybody to clap
up each other for your jobs.
(applause)
I spend enormous amounts of
time trying to be efficient,
trying to figure out
efficiencies for this company.
And something has become
pretty inefficient at scale
given the scale that we're at,
which is the time cycle and cadence
that we deploy promotions and raises.
And so, we do that on
a month to month basis.
We really do it on a day to day basis,
and there's a lot of
work that goes into it.
So, to find efficiencies
we are gonna go to
a more structured, more
infrequent pay bumps
and promotion period.
Minnie will give the
details four times a year,
things of that nature.
The reason I kind of wanted
to make sure everybody
heard it from the horse's mouth is
nobody that's gonna get
caught up in the new cycle,
much like we did with VMap with the CMs
will be negatively affected, if anything.
Some people may get accelerations
depending on the timing.
But in 2016 we're going to go,
and Minnie will talk about it real quick,
and then we'll send an
email with all the details.
But we're gonna go into
a different cadence of
not month to month with
promotions and raises,
but more infrequent, couple times a year,
to make our team more efficient,
make sure we're crossing T's and I's.
But I really thought since, shit.
It's the thing you guys
care about tremendously
because it's your life.
I wanted to make sure
that you guys heard that
the only thing we're doing
with this is to find a cadence.
Not that, "Oh, crap.
"I'm not gonna get a promotion
or raise two months earlier."
Things of that nature.
Once we decided all of
our time has been spent on
nobody left behind that could be affected,
because they were supposed to get
a promotion or raise in February,
but we started in January
and somehow they got affected.
There's no they get burned in April.
And we will go through
that systematically,
but I wanted you to hear that from me
so you understood where
it was coming from.
Thank you, guys. Have
a great day. Thank you.
(applause)
- [Minnie] Hey, guys.
- It's amazing. Show his big face.
Matt, am I gonna change into my tux here?
I also don't want to drag the tux.
- Well that's why we have DRock now.
I don't have to follow you
around the city anymore.
- Are you going to a dinner?
- [Gary] Yes, a gala.
- Oh, have fun.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Let's do it.
- Go ahead.
Yes.
So I'm a big fan of what you just saw
with the all hands on meeting.
I think it's great to
get everybody together
and aligned in one shot.
I think there's a lot of efficiency in it
and for the minor inconvenience of
wrangling everybody up
as you probably saw.
Depending on how DRock wants to edit.
You get to kind of drop a bomb
and everybody gets to see it.
It's just one big moment.
And I find in big organizations,
especially fast, smart, lean organizations
that are roll the way we do.
That there's a lot of the
players at that meeting
that know how to keep up with that
kind of speed and cadence.
And so, I'm proud of that.
I think we've breeded that culture.
And more importantly,
I've watched my company
be able to execute at that kind of level.
And so, I love the all hands on.
It allows me to interact
even at that level
with the employees,
and I like doing them.
So, I'm pretty convinced
they're not gonna let you in
because it's a private club.
There's some rooms that DRock's
not gonna be allowed in.
So, day's going well so far.
Hustle along.
Now the transformation begins.
- So dapper.
- Hi, GV.
- Good to see you.
- It's all dogs. It's all
great. I'm learning a bunch.
- So far so good?
- So far so good and the best part,
and I can say this is all the shit that
I can bring with me from VaynerMedia,
everyone is like, "Ooh."
We worked on Instagram strategy today.
And I was like, "Here are
some seeds of knowledge."
So, I am set up for success thanks to you.
And then we just met up randomly,
and I got to bump into you guys.
And the Jets won yesterday.
- And the Jets won.
- The best part of this run
in is you in a suit though.
- I know it's a very rare.
- Oh, sorry.
- Yeah, DRock eat it.
82nd and 5th.
Where the fuck is everyone?
Now we're headed to the gala
as I'm decked out,
and the best part is the
3:45 a.m. wake up call,
because I have a 5:40 flight tomorrow.
We got it there.
Yep.
Maybe I'll push it to
a 4 a.m. wake up call.
The internet's fault, not your fault?
But it's up right?
Some people right now
will see the new website?
I'm gonna try to pull
up my phone right now
and see if I get it.
Okay, that works.
I'm sure by tomorrow it will.
All right. Cool.
Thanks, brother.
Love you. See you.
All right. Let's see if
I have it on my phone.
That was Zach. New site's not up.
Let me just.
It's been pushed,
but its not showing up
everywhere in the world.
I don't even know how to
spell my name anymore,
because I always type in VaynerMedia.
I actually misspelled it.
DRock, get this.
That's what happens.
I have the old one.
Dammit.
Want to get the new one until
like stick it to them.
No, I'm going to the Charity: Water Gala,
and then tomorrow I have
a 4 a.m. wake up call.
Flying to Miami at 5:40 in the morning.
Keeping it real.
Yo.
- How's it going, Gary.
- Good, man. How are you?
- Good. Brandon Harvey.
I'm Snapping for Charity Water.
I just got here from the airport.
I think this is where it is.
- So, that's it.
We got to the gala.
I think that's the title,
"Getting to the Gala."
Charity: Water Gala, an
incredible organization.
Scott Harrison, he's done such a good job,
that I think most of you know
what Charity: Water is,
but if you don't,
DRock, link it up right here.
Great day.
Got a lot in.
Looking forward to seeing Lizzy inside,
spending some time with her,
supporting a tremendous cause.
4 a.m. wake up call.
We'll be here until 11-11:30.
Hanging, jamming, seeing some friends,
doing good stuff.
Really enjoyed having you guys around.
This is really fun.
I'm enjoying you, D-Rock.
See you soon.
Maybe, I'll try to get
some footage in there.
Thank you.
Some amazing stuff.
An amazing place.
Hello.
This way?
Thank you.
It's getting louder.
So, it means I'm close.
- [Speaker] Thanks to you
guys for buying tickets,
for buying tables, for
contributing to this event.
We've already helped a lot of people.
You're going to hear more about that later
and the goal,
but we're so so excited.
You guys could be anywhere tonight,
and you chose to spend your time with us.